the USS Theodore Roosevelt's commanding
officer has been relieved of duty by the
Navy after a raising alarm bells about a
growing number of sailors sick with Cova
19 on his aircraft carrier our national
security correspondent Jennifer Griffin
is live from the Pentagon with more on
this story good morning Jennifer good
morning ad hours after the acting Navy
secretary fired captain Brett Crozier
hundreds of crew members gathered on the
USS Roosevelt's hangar bay to give him a
roaring send-off chanting his name 114
sailors have now tested positive for
Kovan 19 on board the aircraft carrier
it appears the crew is ignoring
guidelines to social distance to send a
message of protest to top Navy brass for
firing their skipper who sounded alarm
bells about the rising number of
coronavirus cases on his ship forced to
earth to arrive in Guam a week early I
did not come to this decision lightly I
have no doubt in my mind that captain
Crozier did what he thought was in the
best interest of the safety and
well-being of his crew unfortunately it
did the opposite it unnecessarily raised
alarms with the families of our sailors
and Marines with no plan to address
those concerns on Sunday captain Crozier
wrote a letter that leaked to his
hometown newspaper the San Francisco
Chronicle in the letter Crozier is
urging senior Navy leaders to offload
most of the 5,000 sailors on board
immediately
to disinfect the ship adding the spread
of the disease is ongoing and
accelerating quote we are not at war
sailors do not need to die if we do not
act now we are failing to properly take
care of our most trusted asset our
sailors the acting Navy secretary said
the Roosevelt captain had acted
emotionally without discussing the
letter with his immediate strike group
commander who was just down the hall on
board the ship instead the letter was
sent over an unsecured unclassified
email system this does not have a
chilling effect on other Navy captain's
what he did by doing by doing this and
not being careful with who that
information went to but it was copied to
20 or 30 other people okay that that's
just not acceptable he did not
take care and what that did is created a
panic on the little bit of a panic on
the ship
well they said he had no evidence the
captain leaked the letter to his
hometown newspaper but suggested the
Navy was already expediting help for the
ship including arranging 1700 hotel
rooms in Guam when the letter appeared
in the newspaper Tuesday edy
all right Jennifer Griffin thank you